conservative pundit and Coulter has
occasionally been critical of Donald
Trump and she is now calling for Trump
to go what pushed her over the edge
Trump saying that some of the kids who
were brought to the United States by
their undocumented immigrant parents are
no angels except what she's mad about is
not that Trump is going after innocent
kids
it's that Trump is saying that they
might be allowed to stay if he gets his
way this is actually interesting because
when you look at the tweet that she
quoted and sent out it's not obvious
whether she's angry that Trump is
attacking kids or angry that Trump is
going to allow the kids to stay but when
you look at it and you understand Ann
Coulter it makes more sense Donald Trump
tweeted yesterday quote many of the
people in daca no longer very young are
far from angels some are very tough
hardened criminals President Obama said
he had no legal right to sign order but
would anyway if Supreme Court remedies
with overturn a deal will be made with
Dems for them to stay so most people saw
that tweet and they were disgusted that
Donald Trump was going after children
who are in the u.s. through no fault of
their own by calling them no angels and
tough hardened criminals and coulter
quoting Donald Trump's tweet and adding
quote okay that does it I give up they
can stay you must go might suggest to
you that she's angry that Trump is
calling these kids criminals and that
they're no angels that's not the right
interpretation an Coulter is apparently
upset that Trump is saying daca
recipients will be allowed to stay in
the United States
she's been tweeting anti daca amnesty
messages she wants Trump to be more
aggressive on this issue of immigration
stunningly as if Trump hasn't done
enough damage already so this is an
example of a disaffected right winger
but it's kind of the opposite of many
lots of Republicans are disgusted with
Trump going too far in many cases
against the Constitution against the
rule of law Coulter's the opposite she's
upset Trump isn't hardline enough on
immigration but still any prominent
disaffected right winger with Trump who
public
Klee says so is a little crack in the
armor I used that term earlier in the
show and I'm using it again we don't
know what might make any right wing or
opt to stay home in November of 2020 or
vote for someone else and at crazy as it
sounds to us to follow an Coulter's lead
on anything some people actually respect
her I know it's shocking and they might
decide based on what she says not to
vote for Donald Trump so we'll take all
of it and meanwhile we will push our
strategy of get out the vote and
everything else that we've been
discussing and see where it gets us in
November of 2020